[Musique]
bonsoir lundi 14 décembre très heureux
de vous retrouver pour une nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur tv
60,18 bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition
voici les titres le confinement des
effets positifs sur les routes en
novembre le nombre de morts a connu une
baisse record par rapport à l'année
dernière mais dans le même temps une
tendance émerge aussi les excès de
vitesse sont explosés sur des axes
déserté nous en parlons avec jean yves
petit directeur du comité des divines de
l'association prévention routière les
conseillent également 2e pilote stéphane
panepinto pour rouler en toute sécurité
l'hiver depuis le 28 novembre les
commerces dits non essentiels ont pu
rouvrir avec un protocole sanitaire
renforcée pour veiller au respect des
règles en pleine pandémie de kobe 19 un
contrôle surprise a été menée vendredi
dernier dans un centre commercial du
chéné rocancourt est alors de nombreuses
commune yvelinoise y ont renoncé cette
année la bergerie nationale a bien
proposé son marché de noël ce week end
35 exposants étaient présents pour
l'événement solidarité également dans
cette édition avec à suivre dans ce
journal cette opération une distribution
de pommes de terre qui s'est déroulée ce
week-end à elancourt et qui a profité
notamment à des associations
mais avant de développer ses titres
souvenez vous c'était le 2 décembre
dernier le coffrage d'une poutre de plus
de 300 tonnes s'effondrait sur les rails
du rer c à paris résultat un trafic très
perturbé et des lourds travaux de
déblayage en urgence à mener après 13
jours de chantier la ligne est de
nouveau mise en service déblayage
travaux non-stop durant 72 heures sur le
caténaire ont été nécessaires pour se
faire malgré cette remise en service le
trafic du rer c est resté difficile
aujourd'hui en raison d'un mouvement
social un train sur trois circulait
jusqu'à demain circulent jusqu'à demain
sur l'ensemble de la ligne mouvement qui
touche également plus localement les
lignes n ai eu du transilien avec 3
trains sur 4 assuré ce lundi
[Musique]
transport toujours du rail on passe à la
route avec mon invité jean yves petit et
bonsoir bonsoir d'être le directeur du
comité des divines de l'association
prévention routière avec vous on parle
des derniers chiffres de la sécurité
routière alors en novembre 170 personnes
sont décédées sur les routes contre 257
le même mois en 2010 9 ce qui représente
une baisse record 33,9 pour cent en
moins soit avec 87 17 ans - en tout et
dans le même temps aussi plus d'excès de
vitesse on va en parler dans un instant
cette baisse avait déjà été perceptible
lors du premier confinement est ce que
finalement le fait qu'ils aient moins de
monde sur les routes peut être y at il
moins d'accidents est ce que c'est la
seule raison faut-il en chercher
d'autres
enfin c'est la raison qui tombe sous le
sens évidemment il ya eu pendant les de
confinement et surtout celle du
printemps beaucoup beaucoup moins de
circulation et donc beaucoup moins
l'accident est beaucoup moins
d'accidents graves et en particulier
dans notre département
pendant les mois de avril et mai il ya
eu aucun tué sur les routes du
département ce qui est gelée dire
malheureusement mes skis et ski et ce
qui est très rare c'est la même tendance
la sur le mois de novembre en tout cas
sur ce deuxième coup fumant avec
toutefois un petit bémol puisque
le printemps c'est les beaux jours là le
mois de novembre c'est l'automne et la
nuit qui tombe plutôt donc il ya
d'autres risques dont on va peut-être
parler dans un instant ce conte ce qu'on
disait s'il ya de bons chiffres certes
mais il faut rester prudent vous le
disiez la nuit vient plus vite
maintenant avec les avec l'hiver y aussi
les fêtes qui arrive forcément la
sécurité routière a d'ailleurs lancé une
campagne qui s'appelle un appel à la vie
via des affiches via quatre films avec
des slogans la vie est trop douce pour
griller un stop la vie est plus grande
qu'un record de vitesse sur l'a 6 la vie
est plus forte qu'un dernier verre avant
de prendre la route
est ce que vous craignez justement
qu'avec ces fêtes qui approche je suis
aussi à partir de demain le confinement
qui sera remplacé pour un parent un
couvre feu donc peut-être davantage de
circulation est ce que vous craignez que
les chiffres repartent à la hausse
c'est après un oui bien sûr c'est à
craindre qu'il y à un relâchement en
plus
premièrement à cause du déconfinement et
puis deuxièmement à cause de la proche
des fêtes
ça va probablement cumuler les risques
donc oui il ya effectivement des risques
que que les gens soient moins prudent
est en tout cas plus sur la route est
également moins prudent et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui avait été observé lors
de la levée du premier confinement il y
avait eu les des chiffres qui étaient
repartis à la hausse
oui mais c'est vrai mais c'est assez
humain à vrai dire les gens ont été sous
pression ou confinés
contraint pendant une période
relativement longue donc après
naturellement il ya un relâchement font
pas que ce relâchement soit trop
flagrant sur la route mais
malheureusement c'est arrivé mais l
approche des fêtes ont cédé des dangers
qu'ils sont en augmentation et votre
association le comité des yvelines sera
mobilisée notamment il ya prochain
rendez-vous qui concerne justement c'est
cette période alors oui tous les ans
nous faisons une action de distribution
d'éthylotests et de tracts pour inciter
les gens à être prudents à l'occasion
des fêtes sur l'alcool bien sûr et
pouvoir rentrer chez soi en toute
sécurité
donc cette année nous distribuerons nos
éthylotests et nos bons conseils à la
gare de versailles chantiers jeudi 17 à
partir de 17h on a parlé de la partie on
va dire positive avec des chiffres qui
baissent sur la mortalité ça donc c'est
pour la partie positive qui est aussi
une partie négative jean yves petit avec
certes moins de monde sur les routes
moins de bouchons mais des excès de
vitesse qui explosent à les radars ont
relevé une augmentation de 47 4% des
excès de vitesse supérieur à 50 km heure
par rapport au mois de novembre 2019
comment l'expliquer finalement et bah
c'était aussi très flagrant au cours du
premier confinement encore plus parce
que c'était le printemps et les beaux
jours
mais les routes étant vide ben certain
nombre d'automobilistes se sont crus
autorisés à appuyer sur le champignon au
donc ils ont eu des îles ont été
verbalisés bien sûr mais il ya eu aussi
des accidents forcément plus grave
puisque les gens sont allés plus vite
moins d'accidents puisque avait beaucoup
moins de monde mais des accidents plus
graves
est ce que c'est de nature à vous
inquiéter cette tendance d'un côté une
mortalité qui baissent mais aussi des
excès de vitesse qui montrent ce qui est
assez inquiétant c'est qu'on a toujours
un certain nombre de nos concitoyens qui
qui prennent ça à mon sens un peu trop à
la légère gouin
en commettant des excès de vitesse de
grand excès de vitesse comme vous l'avez
dit c'est me paraît pas très raisonnable
ça me paraît pas très raisonnable restez
avec nous d'abord ce reportage vous
l'avez sûrement remarqué sur votre
pare-brise qu'il a fallu sans doute
gratter la semaine dernière les
températures hivernales sont déjà là
dans les yvelines pour rouler en toute
sécurité quelques gestes simples sont à
suivre
quels sont ils le pilote stéphane
panepinto originaire de montigny le
bretonneux vous donne ses conseils
reportage sur le circuit jean-pierre
beltoise à trappes avec michael et demi
d'euros comment conduire par temps froid
le pilote automobile stéphane panepinto
est venu tester ce jour-ci sur le
circuit beltoise à trappes une voiture
équipée de roulettes le but simuler les
plaques de verglas avant de se lancer
sur la route le pilote recommande de
s'assurer du bon fonctionnement du
véhicule des freins des essuie glaces et
de s'équiper de pneus hiver
déjà c'est reconnaissables par le
symbole qui est dessiné sur le pneu on
voit les flocons neige
donc ça c'est la première chose ensuite
on voit là le dessin du pneu les
sculptures qui sont beaucoup plus
profondes ce qui permet une meilleure
évacuation soit de l'eau s'il neige pas
où l'accumulation de la neige parce
qu'il faut savoir que rien n'avait mieux
sur la neige que la neige
donc le fait que la neige s'accumule
dans les sculptures permet une meilleure
adhérence ensuite dans la voiture le
spécialiste insiste sur le fait d'être
bien installé d'avoir la tête bien
droite ne pas être trop couvert il faut
avoir un pare brise bien propre et sans
lui et objectif pouvoir anticiper au
maximum sur la route pack de verglas
alors déjà il faut qu'on ait une vitesse
adaptée ça c'est essentiel si l'on
pourra jamais maîtriser le véhicule
ensuite ces deux légèrement poser le
pied sur le frein sans trop freiner pour
ne pas bloquer les roues parce que c'est
là où arrivent les difficultés c'est on
bloque les routes
par le contrôle de la voiture il
rattrapable parce qu'en plus la voiture
va prendre de la vitesse donc on
accentue le danger en cas de fortes
neiges sur les routes yvelinoise le
pilote stéphane pénet pinto vous
recommande de rester chez vous et de
télétravail est un joli petit des
conditions qui peuvent être plus
difficiles sur les routes l'hiver il
faut le dire aussi le principal danger
l'hiver c'est la nuit qui qui arrivent
plus vite
absolument c'est là dessus que je
voudrais insister la nuit arrive en plus
vite
il faut bien se concerte pas tellement
les automobilistes à vrai dire mais je
m'adresse plus tôt aux piétons et aux
cyclistes qui eux ont pas forcément
conscience de ça et combien de fois je
vois à la sortie des collèges en ce
moment où il fait lui les collégiens qui
sortent habillés en noir parce que c'est
la mode et qui enfourchent leur vélo ou
leur trottinette sans feu sans rien donc
on ne les voit pas ils prennent de gros
risques
la justice et être visibles être vus
être vu et s'équiper comme ça va être
fait réglementairement ou même si c'est
pas une obligation dans le code de la
route
portez des vêtements enfin un gilet
réfléchissant gilet réfléchissant aussi
vous l'avez dit l'éclairage qui est
important les vérifications aussi à
faire sur son véhicule si on passe sur
la partie véhicule à l'hiver oui sur la
partie voiture mais bon je veux faire
aussi régulièrement bien sûr je ne
reviendrai pas sur ce qu'a dit stéphane
panepinto c'est un professionnel de la
route je me permettrai pas de revenir
dessus
si vous le permettez jusqu'à 1 quelques
chiffres en 2019 dans notre département
nous avions déjà un nombre de tués
historiquement bas
il y avait eu 28 tués sur les routes du
département alors que les années
précédentes c'était 47 48 49
donc c'était historiquement bas et on
n'a pas bien su l'expliquer et surtout
qu'en 2020 évidemment les chiffres sont
complètement fausses et avec les
confinements est là et les mesures
sanitaires mais nous sommes aujourd'hui
à 23 tués sur les routes dans le
département dont des villes des
cyclistes et un nombre relativement
important par rapport aux années
précédentes de piétons d'où la nécessité
d'être d'être visible
pour les piétons et les cyclistes avec
cette nuit qui tombe plutôt merci jean
yves petit d'être venu en plateau pour
en parler
je rappelle que vous êtes le directeur
du comité des yvelines de l'association
prévention routière
merci et à jeudi à la guerre des
chantiers pour distribuer les
éthylotests dans l'actualité toujours
l'épidémie de kovy de 19 à partir de
demain le confinement sera remplacé par
un couvre-feu élargi de 20 heures à 6
heures du matin une dérogation sera
possible la nuit du 24 décembre pour
aller fêter noël en famille mais pas
pour la nuit de la saint sylvestre à
cause des derniers chiffres dans les
yvelines
le nombre de personnes contaminées pour
100000 habitants ce qu'on appelle le
taux d'incidence est reparti à la hausse
sur une semaine plus 7,4 et les autres
indicateurs sont en revanche à la baisse
taux de positivité aux tests taux
d'occupation des lits de réanimation en
ile-de-france qui revient quasiment à
50% 786 personnes étaient hospitalisées
hier sur le territoire et blinois moins
deux ans une semaine 57 patients étaient
toujours en réanimation à 55 décès
supplémentaires ont été recensés en une
semaine dans les hôpitaux du département
ce qui porte à 9 171 le nombre de
victimes depuis le début de cette
épidémie de covile 19 malgré la crise
sanitaire le gouvernement a autorisé les
commerces a dit non essentiels à rouvrir
depuis le 28 novembre dernier ils
doivent respecter cependant un protocole
sanitaire a renforcé vendredi dernier ce
centre commercial du chéné rocancourt a
donc reçu une visite surprise est de la
direction départementale de la
protection des populations
un contrôle préventif pour s'assurer de
l'application des mesures justin brasier
nicolas landry un contrôle surprise pour
le centre commercial westfield parly 2
objectif veiller au respect du protocole
sanitaire renforcée face aux copies de
donc le marquage au sol les
les affichages préventive pour le basque
obligatoire le fait la distanciation et
on s'assure aussi qu'il n'y a pas de
de regroupement qui gère bien la jauge
du nombre de personnes présentes au sein
du magasin
plus personne ne rentre pas la visite se
voulait pédagogique
elle visait à accompagner les
commerçants dans la mise en place du
protocole les règles de prévention sont
strictes
nous comprenons que pour les commerçants
grand petit ça suppose une adaptabilité
des personnes des clients etc
donc nous sommes là pour accompagner
cette respect des run encore une fois
dans un esprit pédagogique
l'occasion de faire le point sur les
mesures déjà mises en place une
application a notamment été développé
sur téléphone pour réguler le flux de
personnes en temps réel dans le centre
commercial
là on a le nom de personnes en présence
de ses trois mille neuf cent soixante et
une personnes
donc lorsqu'on attend en fait des seuils
critiques
on a donc des alertes donc le seuil il
est à 75%
le premier seuil dans ces cas là notre
dispositif se met en place c'est à dire
que nos agents vont aux portes se mettre
en place pour commencé à filtrer les
entrées un nouveau passage surprise aura
lieu prochainement pour vérifier la mise
en place des mesures dans la structure
réouverture depuis quelques jours sous
protocole donc des commerces non
essentiels les établissements culturels
n'ont pas eu cette chance et doivent
patienter encore pendant trois semaines
minimum les musées les cinémas mais
aussi les théâtres donc celui de saint
quentin en yvelines
elles ne pourront donc pas levé le
rideau avant le 7 janvier minimum son
directeur lionel massey tard sans une
certaine colère suite à cette décision
gouvernementale interview express
collectées par nicolas landry
[Musique]
là c'est une c'est quand même une pointe
de une pointe de colère et d'énervement
qui qui commença qui commence à monter
parce qu'il y a d'une part le sentiment
que il ya de vrais incohérences dans le
dispositif et puis le sentiment surtout
que c'est un choix politique c'est à
dire ce n'est pas un choix qui est
uniquement un choix sanitaire c'est un
choix qui est politique
finalement on n'est pas un secteur non
essentiel pour le gouvernement on est un
secteur inutiles ou bien le secteur que
l'on peut toucher finalement sans que ça
fasse beaucoup de mal
pour l'instant on a été extrêmement
j'allais dire presque dos il est
certainement un peu trop docile donc il
ya de fortes chances que l' on utilise
les voies de droit qui sont à notre
disposition et le monde delà de la
culture et des arts est aussi structuré
en association en syndicat donc il ya de
fortes chances que ce soit la décision
qui va être prise
les conséquences sont multiples c'est
les conséquences financières fait
vraiment pour le théâtre avant j'allais
dire presque au second plan même si
elles sont considérables mais c'est les
conséquences pour les publics et puis
des conséquences pour des artistes qui
sont qui sont considérables c'est à dire
que la période qui va de novembre
jusqu'au mois de janvier c'est la
période traditionnellement dé ce qu'on
appelle les sorties de création
c'est-à-dire les premières des
spectacles les premières que les
programmateurs peuvent voir pour les
programmes et la saison suivante
cette période là n'existe pas c'est à
dire que vous avez des dizaines des
centaines de compagnies qui ont
travaillé pendant un an deux ans trois
ans pour monter des productions qui
devait sortir là et qui ne sortiront pas
avec plus de 300 personnes recrutées ce
dispositif a permis neuf mille visites
auprès de 8000 seniors le dispositif y
est plus yvelines étudiants seniors et
redéployer par le département du 14
décembre au 31 mars
le principe des jeunes sont recrutés
pour effectuer des visites de
convivialité assurée une écoute ou
encore téléphoner à ses seniors
l'objectif lutter contre l' isolement
exacerbée en cette période de crise
sanitaire et des agents de convivialité
vont donc être recrutés il faut avoir
plus de 16 ans être lycéen ou étudiant
être en recherche d'emploi plus
d'information au numéro qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran le département des
yvelines va débourser à 800000 euros
pour cette opération écouler des stocks
à prix coûtant depuis quelques jours un
producteur de pommes de terre nordiste
se rend dans diverses communes
yvelinoise pour vendre ses produits
des distributions qui s'accompagne aussi
de dons plusieurs associations ont ainsi
pu récupérer de grandes quantités pour
leurs bénéficiaires exemple à elancourt
samedi dernier avec mélanie poké et
nicolas landry samedi matin la croix
rouge vient de récupérer un ton inédit
150 kg de pommes de terre directement du
producteur
cinq associations du territoire ont pu
récupérer les denrées
c'est bien ça va nous aller pour la
semaine voit pas trop les garder
longtemps et puis ça va ça va être bien
pour distribuer gratuitement la semaine
prochaine une fois par semaine ya des
distributions alimentaires et donc ça
aidera à améliorer le colis des pommes
de terre parce que des produits frais
c'est pas toujours évident d'en avoir
après la verrière et rappelé les
agriculteurs installés dans le nord de
la france ont fait une halte à elancourt
un geste de solidarité déjà c'est
important c'est pas normal en tant que
producteur qu'on doive jeter de la
marchandise
les associations si vous voulez elles
sont vraiment elles ont beaucoup plus de
personnes qu'avant la actuellement il ya
environ alors les restos du coeur vient
de me dire justement qu'ils ont 40% de
plus de personnes en situation de
précarité que l'antre l'an dernier on
essaie vraiment de travailler en lien
avec toutes ces associations
on travaille vraiment partenariat et
puis on les soutient sur le plan
logistique
les associations ont récupéré entre 100
et 500 kg chacune 22 tonnes ont été
proposés à la vente
le sport est une pluie de podium ce
week-end pour le cercle des nageurs de
l'ouest de saint germain en laye
engagées dans les championnats de france
de natation championnats de france
hivernaux grand bassa saint-raphaël dans
le var d'abord avec vous le voyez à 15
ans seulement justin delmas qui décroche
sa première première médaille d'or sur
le 100 m brasse seniors l'yvelinois a
signé la meilleure performance française
de sa catégorie
par la même occasion avec une minute 8
secondes et 83 centièmes vous voyez
dorénavant alex portal alex portable qui
au même moment à angers elle lors des
championnats de france handisport petit
bassin a battu à 18 ans tenez vous bien
quatre records du monde 400 m nage libre
100 m nage libre 100 m dos et 400 m 4
nages également deux records d'europe et
un record de france pour lui lors de ces
championnats de france le sportif mal
voyant de naissance et vice champion du
monde de 200 m bravo à lui pour refermer
ce journal la magie des fêtes s'est
emparé ce week-end de la bergerie
nationale alors que de nombreuses
communes ont décidé d'annuler
leur marché de noël le site de
rambouillet organiser le sien hier
dimanche retour sur l'événement avec
mélanie poker en circuit à respecter un
temps plutôt frisquet mais la magie de
noël a tenu chaud aux visiteurs à
rambouillet en trouve ça bien là tout un
circuit qui est mis en place donc on
sait en sécurité et puis bah ça nous
permet de sortir de faire des achats
ça donne aussi des idées bien sûr et
puis on fait un dépôt de nos achats là
c'est agréable d'être dehors de prendre
l'air et de voir des belles choses quand
même 35 exposants ont répondu présent à
l'appel de la bergerie nationale des
artisans principalement locaux qui
attendent souvent beaucoup des marchés
de noël pour moi l'an dernier s'est
représenté 70 % de mon chiffre
d'affaires annuel
je les lis des bijoux en verre que je
travaille au chalumeau et ils sont
montés dons soit sur acier inoxydable
soit sur argent au surhomme essais sont
caducs et cynique puisque jamais parce
que il y avait eu beaucoup de marchés
qui ont été annulés et ça fait plaisir
aux visiteurs et aux producteurs
c'est la période où on vend la bière de
noël et
c'est également les activités des ventes
directes et les marchés avec le 2ème
confinement de nombreuses animations dû
être annulés ce marché de noël est vécue
comme un soulagement
franchement ça nous fait vraiment du
bien le voilà les gens ont du sang du
patient t on était ouvert pour les
scolaires du lundi au vendredi mais
fermé mercredi samedi dimanche depuis
les vacances de la toussaint on voit que
les gens ils ont à la fois envie d'aller
se promener sur la ferme d'aller à la
rencontre des animaux et se promener sur
le marché le marché de noël mais
effectivement les gens sont au rendez
vous et si les distances devait être
respecté entre les visiteurs il y en a
deux pour qui cette journée était plutôt
câline voilà c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de votre fidélité très belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]